the machines are taking over AI will
soon control the entire world but it's
not quite there yet very close but for
now there's still sometimes a little bit
of a Chasm and so the producers have
generated very sophisticated AI images
and it will be up to me to Guess The
Prompt of the
images this would be Claud Dean gay the
president of Harvard accepting her Oscar
for
best acting you know meaning like she's
lying she's pretending something like
that cluding gay winning an Oscar okay
good I went even further that was good
all right all right this is good that
was an easy one Donald Trump May is
giving a speech looks like a writing
desk from the Congress or like an old
timey one but it might might be a
version of alurn Donald
Trump giving a speech in a cornfield in
Iowa ballot harvesting that's good you
get it ballot harvesting some people are
saying like Trump winning iow Trump and
a corn field didn't we used to play this
game since lady we did I kind of wanted
to bring it back Trump leading the field
that was a good guess Trump outstanding
in his field that's pretty good ballot
harvesting that's good he's not
harvesting in the picture so AI needs to
work on that a little okay next
one Dr
fouchy as a quack Joe Biden is a lame
duck a darn lame duck that's that's good
the duck thing threw me off cuz I was
thinking of the Chris Christie
devastating attack you remember when
Chris Christie got up there and he said
Donald you're not coming to this debate
so now we're going to call you Donald
Duck and everyone just groaned in the
audience and then somehow Christy's
campaign went on for another six months
Joe Biden is a lame duck did you guys
get that one Donald Biden lame yeah okay
couple people got the lame dock okay
this one um is that Professor Jacob in
the Jew tunnels
I knew it I knew it they're look they're
making Professor Jacob look fairly Chad
in that picture but it's still I could
tell because of the hair is kind of a
professor hair and then um those tunnels
obviously are a perfect depiction of the
Jewish tunnels underneath Brooklyn
that's I just the thing with Professor
Jacob there though why isn't he working
he's not digging you know he's not like
digging fast he's just standing there
posing for a picture Jacob yeah okay I
think everyone got Jacob in the Jew
[Music]
tunnels is this the Polish
Insurrection RFK Jr falling in the polls
okay oh get it I just don't wait who's
RFK Jr in this the main guy is supposed
to be Bobby Kennedy it doesn't look
anything like him and the polls is funny
CU you get it it's a play on words
supposed to be p o l LS but it's p o l s
you get it so there's the flag so I
thought it was like the polish
Insurrection you know AI is not that
good at public figures oddly enough it's
it's not bad at Trump but it's not that
good at a lot of public figures is that
margerie Taylor Green
in marjerie Taylor Green
Day man yeah kid let's
go oh man that was a good one it it was
the spiky hair that finally gave it to
me margerie Taylor Green Day MTG and
Blink 182 say chicken soup closed MTG
day yeah okay people got the MTG day
that's good okay next one is it Michelle
Obama is Cleopatra it's not like funny
big yeah oh wow okay I got it except you
used the you used the um the new
identification maybe the old
identification of Michelle Obama yeah
some wow Lord of the Ring Jesus Freak
also goes Michael Obama is Cleopatra
like they even got that wow oh this is
Matt Walsh talking to a demon h
I think I got that right pretty sure I
got that right okay that's our show I'm
Michael NS this the Michael NS show see
you
tomorrow right now go to Jus cell.com
nyt let's make a resolution that you are
sure to stick with with genus cell
skincare you can turn back the clock and
look 5 10 even 15 years younger right
now genus cell skincare is celebrating
2024 with its New Year's Sales Event you
will save over
77% off all must haves in their most
popular package say goodbye to those
Fine Lines forehead wrinkles sagging
jawline dark marks skin redness and
under eyb don't wait jus.com
YT code Shadow aliens have
landed